therefore like you know it's all about
the people
we brought people that
could make fortune in other companies
but they like the mission of like
solving hard problems
everything is cognate is open we're not
we're working with open spaces and open
rooms everybody knows what everybody's
doing although we're like close to 70
people already
so we're like kind of like both of the r
and d and their product and marketing
and the sales they know what are the
problems where we are trying to solve
how we are going to do it and are
communicating all around it's kind of
like an open way of communicating what
you do and people love that
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillary stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders let's talk about the autonomous
driving space meet danietsmon ceo of
cognata
danny is a seasoned technologist and
subject matter expert in the domains of
machine learning computer vision and
automated driving leveraging this unique
expertise danny has been in the business
of launching high-tech products for more
than 20 years
he served as harman's now samsung
director of advanced driver assistance
systems and senior director of machine
learning and has co-founded several
technology companies operating in the
intersection of artificial intelligence
and automotive technology
daniel welcome to 20 minute leaders how
are you
i'm great thank you michael great to be
here how are you
i am doing fine thank you so much for
joining me i love talking about
autonomous vehicles and really i love
talking about deep technology in general
that you know that manifests itself
towards a greater future that is both
saving a lot of lives on the road but is
also just just really really really cool
and with kokonata today you're really
you know enabling
the development towards autonomous
vehicles and you know if i think about
you know what kind of thing people would
think about in autonomous vehicles in
their day-to-day it's probably not what
kognata does which i think is also a
really cool aspect of what you're doing
because sort of behind the scenes of how
this whole thing is operating so i'll
let you explain the rest tell me a
little bit about yourself and then we'll
transition to talk about autonomous
vehicles
okay so i'm daniel smoan i'm
the ceo and founder of cognata uh i'm
what's called like a serial entrepreneur
it's like my third company uh
in sirius
the last top companies were like in the
field of computer vision and the
the company before cognata was acquired
by the t1 harman it was a company called
iron road
it did
advanced driver assistance systems
on a smartphone became quite successful
and was acquired by t1 and i ran
advanced driver assistance functionality
like know the generation that you have
currently on your vehicle this was what
i was developing and
something like you know six
years ago five years ago i like talked
about like the whole problem again and i
understood that the way that the
industry is like
the way it goes it would never converge
and solve the problem without a good
simulation platform like you have like
tons of sensors
a lot of inputs you need to learn
driving behaviors of humans and like
anticipate the unknowns unknowns and
there was there wasn't any systems that
could handle that
so i left my very cozy uh walk in
harmony
and they know we call it to go to the
desert and now start from scratch
everything the problem how we can solve
it
better in a much more efficient and
explainable way and that was the forming
of kugnata meaning of the name
cognition and data
in order like if you think about
autonomous driving you're talking about
deep learning
based technologies
and this is the kind of technology that
learns by example
you show it like uh
annotated or like bounding boxes of
people in an image or in a lidar view it
will learn how to generalize that
and the way that it was done
like
when i was developing was
to take
a manual snapshot or videos and do like
manual labeling of that stuff
and you need like billions of images
like to generalize that and this is not
the way to go
you need some kind of like scalable
manner of doing that and
that was like the idea behind forming
not an automatic way like a realistic
simulator that will enable you to create
this data it comes fully annotated with
full ground proof that you can learn
from and get much faster uh to what you
need i love it why
there were there were two parts of this
question first it was why the automotive
industry why mobility and i want both
parts of the answer and then i and then
a little bit about you know the startup
journey and being a serial founder in
the space
yeah okay so let's like three questions
try to remember all of them so
um
why mobility
it goes a long way with me like it's one
of my
favorite things like my mother told me
that as a kid when i was three years old
i was recognizing
all the
all the vehicles
logos um
out there on the road it's something
that i loved
uh and then
[Music]
when i got uh you know
older
uh i kind of recognized there were like
three platforms that you could like
bring innovations
uh the first one was like uh the pc
then the pc was exchanged with the with
the smartphone
and then came the vehicle like uh you
see like the issue of generation like
you know you're like adding more and
more compute so you got into kind of
saturation with pc and like
uh the mobile and now the vehicle is the
next a platform where you can bring
innovation
and now
regarding like you know starting from
scratch
oh
i'm come i'm coming from a family of
entrepreneurs like
i kind of investigated that with my
accountants like we just try to
understand if there was any kind of like
um in any generation of my
my family if there was like you know
people that there weren't entrepreneurs
and we tried like four generations you
know into the past and they didn't find
any
so
this is like one it's like you know
it could be that you're like warning
with like uh
that urge the second thing is the
when i'm seeing a problem like seeing a
a
technological problem that can have a
solution is from like a very young age
i'm trying to bring
new solutions to that
and uh i really love like the
the um
the process
of innovating and commercializing
innovation
and
so
you can say it's like you know
family background you can say it's like
you know the way that i was born like uh
but this is like this is me
right
let's let's dive deep into kognata and
specifically into the autonomous vehicle
space and the enablement space
where you know pin me a picture of the
landscape of the of this autonomous
vehicle world
and what what is the gap that you've
observed as you were found in coconata
yeah like
my my background
is with the
computer vision algorithm design
that that was my expertise i started
like you know working on that like seven
years 17 years ago
and it's the main issue
when you are developing
an autonomous vehicle autonomous vehicle
cannot be wrong
or it can be wrong like a human being
and like a human being
almost does not do any arrows you do not
like go
intentionally into red lights or like
you are crazy and will do it or would
not stop on a stop sign you would do
intentionally doing that but a computer
can not allow himself to not recognize
the stop sign or like the red light
um
and bringing a
computer vision
or perception tasks like that to the
level of the human being is a very
hard task
you need to find
all uh
the variations
of the stop sign or of this red light in
order to teach the deep learning system
that we've
talked like in the beginning of this
call
and this variation as a human being you
see
billions
instances of death
when when you're growing up and like
it's easy for you like to recognize
because you saw it you know how it looks
you are like 18 you take your the
vehicle you understand it
you take like a vehicle with a with the
software you need to teach him
and uh
this like for what what i'm
understanding is that
this perception tasks
and the the need of like
data
which is fully annotated and tell you
this like a stop sign or red light
you need those billions of instances
which are diverse enough and interesting
enough to teach your systems is
something that the industry is lacking
and it's really really hard to create
those
uh
and
those data sets in order to teach
autonomous
systems how to see
so this is like the first stage and as
you can see like there's like a full
industry around it
you can see camera manufacturers you can
see lidar manufacturers radars all of
these guys are investing billions of
dollars in order to bring
a computer to the level that it can
recognize every obstacle that
a human with two eyes
is doing and
the second
level that i i see is kind of like
what stops us
uh is
that
you need
like a human eye it's only like let's
say these two eyes
uh i think much better than any
combination that i saw of like cameras
plus sliders plus radars and you have
like a processing power which is 1 000
times faster than any supercomputer that
you know out there
so you know you need
some kind of like balance this uh
equation
and then
from what we think today
uh like you know five years ago in
established cognitive everybody was
saying
we'll do it in two years in three years
there will be like weimar's all over san
francisco but it didn't happen because
this is a hard problem what we're seeing
today
in the industry
is that uh
there's
there are like autonomous vehicle
applications but they're limited
you see that you know in agriculture
you see it with some
construction and mining you sit with
some small shutters just and like you
see like the big investments from waymo
and cruz and the zoox
investing billions into getting to
robotics which i think they will succeed
in like you know three to four or five
years uh we'll start to see it
commercially
very very cool as you're running this
company how much of your of the culture
and of the perspective sort of the
mission of where you're at
is
you know based is rooted in this idea
that you're enabling the future of
autonomous vehicles rather than you know
a a very cool computer vision deep
technology company if you're looking at
sort of the culture or the people that
you get to work with at coconada what
where are you on that spectrum that you
know where sort of the the motivation
for what you're doing
people come to work with in general for
the challenge
like i'm trying to solve hard problems
i'm not trying to
i'm not trying like to take like you
know ed tech or fintech i know this
stuff
we could have been there but i never
liked it i'm trying to solve something
that you know would serve humanity at
the end and i think uh they think the
mission of like bringing autonomous
vehicle which is safe
is
an actual
interesting mission something that they
can work with and can um
um
identify with like they
they like the tasks like uh and and they
feel like that you know what at the end
uh
cognate brings to the market
a
safer
auto autonomous systems
and it's really
cool to see our clients
uh
satisfied with what we're giving them
and and and and their success is my
whole team succeed when where some
customers do like you know uh improving
their perception detection by 30 which
is huge
and like pedestrian detection of like
small kids we enable them to do that you
know like my team
this is what you would like to bring and
not like another like you know cookie
cutter for ethic
right i think that makes a lot of sense
how do you cultivate this
challenge-driven mentality of solving
difficult problems whether it be
through you know your leadership style
through
the way that you approach those problems
so as a leader i'm asking
what do you do in order to really
cultivate and make that you know a core
foundation of the company that you're
building therefore like you know it's
all about the people
we brought people that
could make fortune in other companies
but they like the mission of like
solving hard problems
everything is cognate is open we're not
we're working with
open spaces and open rooms everybody
knows what everybody's doing although
we're like close to 70 people already
so we're like kind of like both of the r
d and their product and marketing and
the cells they know what are the
problems where we are trying to solve
how we are going to do it and are
communicating all around it's kind of
like an open way
of communicating what you do and people
love that
i love it take me back a little bit you
know you mentioned that that your mom
tells you about you already as a kid but
if you go back in time a little bit what
really fascinates you growing up you
know all the way back to elementary
school middle school years
what really you know occupies your brain
yeah like
um as a kid
[Music]
growing in the 80s and we just don't
know like the pc you know the personal
computers coming
i remember going with my with my
brothers to see the the the new tech
uh
in the stores because we could not
afford and when we could afford i i
learned english by by programming when i
was seven or eight
uh so that really fascinated me how how
you can
program and bring like games and like
you know some fun stuff into life with
that
uh when i was older
uh i was starting on to work as really
young kids
like when i was 13
as a programmer
uh
if i'm looking like in high school what
fascinated me
like i liked physics and math of course
but i think i had like one class
on a very old programming language
language called prologue
i think it's the first time that i've
heard about artificial intelligence
and how how you like you know
uh uh teach your computer to think
that's really fascinated me as like you
know a 16 years old
kid
and
and going from that after like you know
serving in in in the army in like a
famous 8 200 unit
i started my entrepreneurship stuff when
i was 20
finishing bc and so
and tried like you know to bring some
something new to the world
i love it
and where do you draw your inspiration
from today so what what in this you know
either your day-to-day in the challenge
in the mission
and in the work that really inspires you
today if i'm thinking about inspirations
inspiration from
the wisdom of like
other entrepreneurs these days
and
looking at the
the work of
jensen wang in nvidia
how he
he
this guy is just amazing like you know
he brought a full technological uh
roadmap nobody believed it was possible
it was
insane what insisted insist about you
know all of his air processor for like a
a decade until it's like finally reached
the point
and today they're like huge company
amazing technological entrepreneur
driven by a mission and knows how to
execute i love this guy this guy
and i met him several times
brings a lot of inspiration of how to do
things right when you are a
technological
entrepreneur like me
um
other than that my kids and my family
know
like they are bringing the innovation
home
there's a lot to learn from these guys
i love it
thank you very very much and best of
luck with natasha thank you for enabling
what's going to be one of the most
amazing revolutions that that i will get
to observe and then i'm very very
excited for that so thank you for all
the hard work and for the inspiring
conversation and stay safe and stay
healthy thank you michael it was a
pleasure for me thank you
you